this episode is sponsored by blinkist
blinkist takes all of the need to know
information from thousands of
non-fiction books and condenses it down
to just 15 minutes and you can go to
blinkist.com microcosmos to learn more
[Music]
[Music]
one of the most frequent questions we
get asked on journey to the microcosmos
is how james our master of microscopes
stays safe while gathering and studying
samples after all as beautiful as the
microcosmos is there are plenty of
parasites and pathogens in there that
we'd prefer to keep under the microscope
and out of our bodies
but while james has simple and effective
guidelines to protect his health like
making sure he always washes his hands
before and after handling samples and
never venturing into a pond with an open
wound there are times when those
measures don't quite cut it these are
the times when no matter how much you
protect yourself outside or inside the
micro cosmos gets the best of you
these are the times of the dust mite
now we don't usually start these videos
with a warning but we're gonna do that
today while working on this video at
least four members of the journey to the
micro cosmos team found themselves
having a bit of a crisis about how clean
their homes were if you found yourself
sneezing and wheezing and running around
miserable with a runny nose because of
dust this arachnid is probably the
culprit though perhaps not in the way
you would expect
dust mites are small in the grand scheme
of things but large in the micro cosmos
hitting just around 300 micrometers in
length their bodies are decked out with
four pairs of legs ending in feet that
act like suction cups as they wander in
their quest for three things water food
and darkness
dust mites love humidity because their
lives depend on it they don't drink
water so much as they osmosis it into
them relying on a salt-filled gland near
their mouth to absorb water vapor from
the air around them so if their
surroundings become more arid an adult
dust mite will wither away until it
eventually dies
this is a challenge for dust mites that
live in places with seasons where wet
and rainy falls give way to dry winters
to survive those shifts they rely on the
resilience of their younger brethren the
nymphs whose forms are able to withstand
that lack of moisture
the seasons of the dust mites life was
one of the important clues that helped
scientists in the 20th century
understand their role in dust allergies
scientists identified dust as the source
of some kind of allergen in the 1920s
but they were not sure what it was
exactly about dust that did it they just
knew that people all over the globe
suffered from dust allergies and that
these allergies were often seasonal
peaking in the autumn particularly after
warm humid summers
and other possible sources like animal
dander or mold just didn't quite fit
right with the seasonality of the
allergy but in the late 1960s scientists
in the netherlands and japan realized
that the dust mite might be the culprit
they're found in large numbers in the
dust that lines the unwashed and
untouched corners of our homes
their populations peaking in time with
the runny noses and bleary eyes of dust
allergies
but while experiments confirmed that
mites really were the source of people's
sensitivities to house dust it wasn't
clear what made them so special so we'll
get to that in a bit
james often finds dust mites in the
humidity chambers he uses to keep his
microbes alive these chambers are made
up of a dish lined with wet toilet paper
which is just about all a dust mite
needs to feel right at home especially
when there's potentially some delicious
microbes to munch on so to keep those
other microbes from becoming a mite meal
james has to regularly clean out and
disinfect the humidity chamber
now that cleaning might get rid of the
dust mites in the humidity chamber but
the problem is that our houses are full
of food for them because our houses are
full of us
of flakes from our skin that shed and
gather all around and sustain the
invisible might and this is a problem
not just because it means the mite can
thrive in our homes it's a problem
because food
means poop
over the course of its life a mite will
produce about a thousand pieces of poop
that are roughly the size of a grain of
pollen
inside those bits of fecal matter are
enzymes that help the dust mite eat its
own poop and get nutrients that it might
not have gotten the first time around
but should the dust mite choose to not
revisit its prior meals the feces will
float around the room attached to other
particles until eventually they settle
down perhaps on a pillow or on a pet's
bed or a car seat it's like we're living
in a gigantic snow globe except that the
snow
is dust mite feces
in 1981 researchers confirmed the bad
news about this animal's poop people are
allergic to it to be more specific they
confirmed that dust mite poop contains
specific proteins that many people are
allergic to
so if you're airing out some sheets and
you start sneezing what you might
actually be reacting to is dust mite
feces flying around the air now we
apologize for this image but it is
reality and it has embedded in our heads
so we have to share it with you as well
but we can offer what might be a small
comfort there is another allergen from
dust mites that has nothing to do with
poop
dust mites have a fairly lengthy mating
process sometimes taking up to two days
to finish this is a pretty lengthy time
for any organism but especially for an
animal that's only got about a hundred
total days to live
over the course of their life the female
dust mite will lay up to 80 eggs which
hatch into larvae that then go through
several different stages of development
before becoming adults
with each passing stage the dust mite
sheds its exoskeleton leaving behind its
youth and that exoskeleton provides some
other allergens for people to react to
but though that is something people are
sometimes allergic to it really is
mostly just the poop that sets off
people's allergies so
i guess there really wasn't that much
comfort there after all
and even for a trained and cautious
microbiologist dust mites can become an
unwelcome surprise once james brought
home some samples taken from a water
dish that his neighbor left outside for
their cat the surface was covered in
tiny round things and james thought they
might be rotifers but when he looked at
the surface of the scum under the
microscope there were no charming
rotifers to be found it was mites just
hundreds of them crawling around the
slide
it was so unpleasant that james
immediately bleached the slide
now he's not sure if that sample is the
reason but for days after james kept
sneezing and having to deal with a runny
nose all of which pointed to a potential
mite invasion fortunately though our
homes are not a utopia for dust mites
what they really need is dark which is
why they prefer to dig themselves deep
into carpets and other soft things that
give them space to burrow
dust mites have a harder time dealing
with materials like suede that are
difficult to hide themselves in and they
usually avoid hard surfaces that are
exposed to light so for james his
weapons against the mite invasion were
clear a vacuum a mattress cleaner and a
strong uv light bulb it is one of the
more ignoble ends to one of our
organisms we don't like to hurt them
unless they're hurting us
but i am sure that there is a dust mite
somewhere in our homes right now
settling into a soft dark abode of its
own with hardly a care in the world for
the battle that was waged to bring you
this video
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and we would like to thank blinkist for
sponsoring today's episode blinkist is
an app that takes the best insights and
need to know information from over 4 000
non-fiction books and condenses them
down into just 15 minutes that you can
read or listen to
maybe you have an idea for a podcast
that just haven't been able to get off
the ground yet well then we highly
recommend checking out everybody has a
podcast except you by justin travis and
griffin mcelroy on blinkist it's a funny
and inspiring hands-on guide to making
your own podcast and it'll walk you
through everything from choosing a topic
to building an audience and you can
check that out right now on blinkist it
can be hard to find the time to sit down
and learn but with blinkist you can
explore their massive library of books
and categories like self-help business
science in history and if you're one of
the first hundred people to sign up
today using blinkist.com microcosmos you
can get free unlimited access for seven
days and you'll also get 25 percent off
if you decide to get a full membership
check out the link in the description to
start your free 7-day trial
it might be that your name is coming up
on the screen right now and if that is
the case i just want to say thank you
these are all of the names of our
patreon patrons they are the people who
make this project possible and without
them we would not be able to continue
exploring all of the nooks and crannies
and ins and outs of the tiny world that
surrounds us so thank you all to all of
our patrons and if you would like to
become one of them you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram or tiktok and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
there's a tickle on my nose oh god